et direction à présent les états unis où
l'assassinât en 1963 de john fitzgerald
kennedy y refait la une des journaux les
archives nationales américaines ont
publié hier pas moins de 1500 documents
en lien avec la mort du 35e président
des états unis alors que contiennent ces
écrits on en parle tout de suite avec
notre correspondante aux abonnés à
washington bon ce soir thomas enquêtes
policières écrits intimes ou encore
discussion privée apparemment ces
documents sensibles où on va aller bien
raviver la flamme des des passionnés de
jeff kate sont très nombreux
oui il y avait beaucoup d'attentes parce
qu'il ya encore beaucoup
d'interrogations sur les circonstances
exactes de la mort de john fitzgerald
kennedy mais je me dois de vous dire
qu'il ya maintenant de la déception
parce qu'il n'y a pas véritablement de
révélations fracassantes dans ces
documents qui ont été publiés cette
semaine alors évidemment l'intégralité
de ces documents n'a pas encore été
analysés ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il
s'agit essentiellement de fichiers issus
de la cia lors il ya un des spécialistes
aux états unis de ce dossier jeff keay
qui se bat d'ailleurs depuis des années
pour la publication intégrale de ces
documents qui s'est déjà penché sur
cette publication lui non plus estime
qu'il n'y a pas de grandes révélations
dans ses fichiers en fait pour lui le
plus notable c'est le fait que ces
données soient désormais numérisés ce
qui va faciliter à l'avenir le travail
des chercheurs et puis surtout il
insiste sur le fait qu'il ya des
éléments qui n'ont toujours pas été
publiés comme par exemple une interview
de la veuve et du frère john fitzgerald
kennedy écouter
ni jaqee ni robert kennedy ne croyait à
la théorie officielle selon laquelle
kennedy aurait été tué par un homme seul
sans raison ils disaient en privé que
jfk y avait été tué par ses ennemis de
l'intérieur s'est su qu'il y assurent
ces enregistrements et c'est pourquoi
ils sont si sensibles
cette version officielle est évidemment
remise en cause depuis des années la
thèse donc de l'assassinât par un homme
seul leach oswald et plus généralement
l'anc est menée par la commission warren
sont souvent remises en question comme
c'était déjà le cas dans le film paru en
1991 par le réalisateur oliver stone
c'est pourquoi beaucoup voix demandent
que tous les documents soient
déclassifiées il faut savoir qu'aux
états unis une loi datant de 1992 impose
la déclassification de ces documents
dans un délai de 25 ans ce qui nous a
menés à octobre 2017 mais depuis entre
temps est des délais supplémentaires ont
été accordés officiellement pour des
raisons de protection de la sécurité
nationale américaine alors donald trump
puis joe biden ont donc autorisé la
publication de certains documents mais
beaucoup d'entre eux sont en fait encore
gardé secret et puis surtout beaucoup de
ces fichiers sont caviardés par souci de
confidentialité ce qui les rend
illisibles pour le grand public il faut
comprendre qu'il ya une forte demande
aux états unis pour connaître toutes les
circonstances autour du décès du 35e
président américain qui a donc été
assassiné le 22 novembre 1963
ça fait bientôt 60 ans c'est vrai qu'on
reste un petit peu sur notre faim chance
et 1500 pages thomas merci en tout cas
pour ces précisions en direct de
washington